das off stahlwerk hunderte kämpfer
wurden rausgeholt und russische gebiete
gebracht ihr schicksal völlig ungewiss
und jetzt erklärt russland stolz dass
sich der stellvertretende kommandeur der
ukrainischen streitkräfte ergeben habe
doch das mal wieder pure propaganda es
war die uslarer mann der der
ukrainischen streitkräfte befindet sich
nämlich noch immer im stahlwerk und er
schickte unseren reportern dieses video
ist es liebe die ukraine heute ist der
85 tag des krieges ich würde die
führungen bleiben noch immer in as of
stars werden gerade maßnahmen
durchgeführt in deren einzelheit sich
nicht nennen kann danke der ganzen welt
und der ukraine für die unterstützung
wir sehen uns herrschen
laut ukraine ist präsident zellen scared
russland nur ein ziel sinnlos die
ukrainischen landsleute töten und ihre
heimat vernichten
die streitkräfte der ukraine setzen die
befreiung der region raki fort aber im
don was versuchen die besatzer den druck
zu erhöhen dort ist die hölle los und
das ist keine übertreibung die brutale
und absolut sinnlose bombardierung von
serotonin zwölf tote und dutzend von
verwundeten an nur einem tag all dies
hat und kann keine militärische
erklärung für russland haben dies ist
ein vorsätzlicher und krimineller
versuch so viele ukrainer wie möglich zu
töten so viele häuser soziale
einrichtungen und unternehmen wie
möglich zu zerstören dies wird man als
völkermord am ukrainischen volk
bezeichnend für den die besatzer mit
sicherheit zur rechenschaft gezogen
werden und
wir sprechen mit pianist ritzel und
zugeschaltet aus kharkiv ukrainische
streitkräfte gelingt es immer mehrere
die russischen truppen zurückzudrängen
sowie auch dort glaubst du dass das
etwas ist eine situation ist sie sie
ausbauen können in den nächsten wochen
also zumindest sah es in den vergangenen
drei vier wochen so aus als könnten die
russischen streitkräfte weiter
zurückgedrängt werden bald über die
russische grenze gedrängt werden wir
waren allerdings in den vergangenen zwei
tage in einigen der befreiten dörfer
dort an der grenze an der grenzregion
nach russland und diese so genannten
befreiten dörfer also die von
ukrainischen streitkräfte mittlerweile
gehalten werden die stehen immer noch
unter schweren artilleriebeschuss unter
unter mörserbeschuss und es gibt jetzt
auch erste meldungen dass an einigen
orten die russischen streitkräfte wieder
eine gegenoffensive gestartet haben dort
wieder boden gut gemacht haben und heute
nacht gab es auch erstmals wieder seit
vielen tagen schwere raketenangriffe
auftrag selbst ich habe noch keinen kein
schadensbild gesehen weiß ja nicht genau
was hier eingeschlagen ist aber es war
heute nacht gegen 3 34 uhr gab es
mehrere schwere angriffe insofern
scheint es so zu sein dass das die
russische streitkräfte tatsächlich
einsatz gesendet haben tatsächlich ihre
stellungen verstärkt haben hier nördlich
von cardiff in einigen dieser dörfer um
ebendiese zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine
weiter zu bedrohen und dort weiter
ukrainische kräfte zu binden was
bedeutet das für die menschen in der
stadt viele wurden ja jetzt auch nach
hause geschickt es hieß die metro werde
bald wieder fahren die schächte also
jetzt nicht mehr unbedingt der ort in
dem man langfristig sicherheit suchen
kann wie gehen die menschen mit dieser
ungewissen situation um
also zumindest als wir die leute die
dort in der metro zuflucht gesucht
hatten sich dort mehrere wochen
aufgehalten haben dann begleitet haben
bei ihrem ersten tag hat es wieder in
ihre wohnung zurückgekehrt haben da war
so eine mischung aus
aus furcht einerseits ist der krieg
zurückkehren könnte andererseits die
vorfreude doch wieder in der eigenen
wohnung leben zu können statt einen
metro schacht und jetzt diesen weiteren
angriffen in diesen anschlägen mit
diesem jahr wirklich schweren
raketeneinschlägen dies gestern nacht
gab es natürlich auch für diese leute
kann man sich vorstellen die vor ich
dann wieder zurückgekehrt allerdings ich
habe jetzt noch nicht gehört ob jetzt
die metro tatsächlich wieder geöffnet
werden soll als bunker insofern muss man
noch abwarten wie sich die entwicklung
in den nächsten 48 stunden denke ich
wird sich das entscheiden herrn stritzel
live aus haake vielen herzlichen dank
dir für deine informationen werden